le producteur roger frappier était
fébrile à l'idée de présenter à la
mostra de venise son film le pouvoir du
chien sans rêve devenu réalité c'est
vraiment une journée mémorable pour moi
énorme le pouvoir du chien est une
adaptation du roman de l'écrivain
américain thomas savage paru en 1967 le
récit se passe en 1925 comme antanas
fils un propriétaire de ranch mène la
vie dure à la nouvelle épouse son frère
roger frappier a eu l'idée il ya huit
ans d'acheter des droits
cinématographiques du livre c'est un
très grand roman méconnu mais très grand
moment que j'ai trouvée par l'agent dans
ma chambre d'hôtel à paris par une nuit
d'insomnie avec lequel je suis
complètement tombé en amour ça m'a pris
une année et demie pour acquérir les
droits mais je savais que c'était moi
qui étais tu fais ce film là c'est bien
le livre habitait aussi la réalisatrice
jane campion la première femme à avoir
remporté la palme d'or au festival de
cannes avec son film la leçon de piano
sorti en 1993 pour le pouvoir du chien
elle fait un retour derrière la caméra
après une absence de 12 avec un film
féministe
le film met en vedette l'acteur benedict
cumberbatch
kristen dunst que nous avons rencontré
la mostra
[Musique]
assène ce que
le pouvoir du chef est distribué par le
géant netflix qui espèrent se retrouver
à la cérémonie des oscars avec ce film
netflix nous a dit surtout à jane
pôles de pouvoir of the dog c'est comme
roma 2
après le tapis rouge à venise l'embargo
critique a été levée sur le film le
pouvoir du chien après l'avoir vu ce que
je peux vous dire c'est qu'il s'agit
d'un grand film de jane campion un film
très poétique rempli de métaphores un
film profond aussi profond que la plaie
dans la main du cowboy fils ici louis
depuis mai radio-canada venise